[Music]  i got a bad feeling about this  what is this place  castle vader the galaxy's first  all-inclusive luxury theme resort feel  the power of the dark side at the empire  emporium now  [Music]  within these walls lies tales almost too  terrifying to tell would you like to  hear them  why is that lightning inside  oh that's a big one  the legendary tales of the sith speak of  the thirst for power oh no join us  and take what you want  the devotion of the undead  a tale of desire i wish i was a pilot  join the imperial academy i  is that really what happened  no it's not  be afraid be very afraid  [Music]  so  what do you think  a little on the news is what i think  everyone gets scared kid  without fear you can't have courage  ears  b1496 1138  [Music]  [Music]  you